y
habla por primera vez la primera dama de
haití tras el ataque en el que murió su
esposo el presidente yo en el mois la
viuda que resultó herida y se encuentra
recuperándose en eeuu atribuye el
asesinato del mandatario a mercenarios
que querían evitar que el fallecido
presidente celebrará un referendo para
aprobar una nueva constitución a finales
de este año
argentina es el nuevo campeón de la copa
américa el albiceleste venció a brasil 1
a 0 y obtuvo su primera victoria en un
campeonato tras 28 años sin títulos
mientras tanto todo está listo para que
inglaterra se enfrente a italia en la
final de la eurocopa 2020 que se jugará
hoy en londres
la humanidad se prepara para presenciar
hoy un hito en el turismo espacial
virgin galactic del multimillonario
británico richard branson enviará un
avión cohete de pasajeros a la frontera
del espacio en su primer vuelo de prueba
con tripulación tenemos informe desde el
lugar del despegue
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz iniciamos en haití la viuda
del presidente asesinado joven el mois
acusó a enemigos sombríos de organizar
el asesinato de su esposo para frenar el
cambio democrático mientras se
intensifica la lucha por el poder el
homicidio de moix el miércoles llevó a
un caos político en haití un país que ya
estaba sumergido en la pobreza y en la
violencia de pandillas el gobierno
interino le pidió a eeuu y a la onu que
envíen tropas para proteger la
infraestructura clave del país
son las primeras declaraciones públicas
de la primera dama de haití desde el
magnicidio ella resultó herida de
gravedad desde el hospital de miami al
que le remitieron martino y publicó un
audio en twitter
estoy llorando es verdad pero no podemos
dejar que el país pierda su rumbo no
podemos dejar que la sangre del
presidente lleven el móvil mi esposo
nuestro mandatario a quien quisimos y
quien nos quiso se derrame en vano
redoblaremos esfuerzos porque la lucha
que él dio no es personal es la batalla
que dio por todos nosotros la tenemos
que continuar con un
las autoridades haitianas culpan a un
comando de 26 colombianos y dos
haitianos estadounidenses por el
asesinato de moix
la primera dama sugirió que ellos fueron
enviados por sus enemigos políticos en
medio del creciente temor y la
inseguridad en el país cerca de 1000
personas se congregaron a las afueras de
la embajada de eeuu el viernes en busca
de un asilo político
no puedo dormir en las noches tuve que
venir aquí a la embajada porque tengo
miedo hay muchos tiroteos y ni siquiera
se sabe de dónde vienen las balas
hasta ahora el primer ministro claude
joseph ha manejado la respuesta ante el
homicidio pero el viernes
ariel en ree a quien me nombró para
reemplazar a joseph y que no sea
posesionado anunció que él formaría un
nuevo gobierno pero yo sé parece tener
las fuerzas de seguridad de su lado y su
gobierno solicitó tropas de eeuu y de la
onu la casa blanca respondió que por
ahora enviar a agentes del fbi el primer
ministro a vida media no las elecciones
en etiopía su partido gobernante el
partido de la prosperidad aseguró 410 de
los cuatrocientos treinta y seis escaños
posibles las elecciones fueron
retrasadas por el cob y 19 y se
celebraron en medio de un frágil cese el
fuego entre fuerzas gubernamentales y
rebeldes en la región de tigre
fue la primera vez que su nombre
aparecía en la papeleta desde que asumió
el cargo en una elección que el primer
ministro había me calificó de histórica
el partido gobernante de la prosperidad
ganó más del 90 por ciento de los
escaños unos comicios boicoteados por la
oposición y con problemas de logística e
inseguridad que implicaron que una
quinta parte del país no pudiera votar
esto es particularmente en el caso en la
región de tigre una operación de
seguridad iniciada en esta región por el
primer ministro en noviembre se
convirtió en un conflicto devastador
esta guerra llevó a asesinatos masivos y
violaciones ha dejado a 400 mil personas
en situación de hambruna
los enfrentamientos han manchado la
reputación del jefe de estado había met
fue nombrado primer ministro para salvar
la coalición que había estado en el
poder desde 1991 fue considerado un
defensor de la unidad en etiopía un país
formado por 10 regiones semiautónomas
divididas según líneas étnicas y puso
fin a un estancamiento de 20 años
pendientes con eritrea
si el pueblo etíope y el pueblo eritreo
están en paz
toda la región del cuerno de áfrica se
puede convertir en una región de paz y
desarrollo
[Música]
sus esfuerzos fueron aplaudidos por la
comunidad internacional y significó un
premio nobel para ahmed en 2019 pero la
figura de reformador fue destrozada el
siguiente año
sus críticos ahora lo acusan de liderar
con el mismo estilo autoritario de sus
predecesores los 28 años sin títulos
argentinas se convirtió en el campeón de
la copa américa tras vencer a brasil 1-0
este sábado en el estadio maracaná de
río de janeiro esta además es la primera
victoria de lionel messi con los
albicelestes en este campeonato y fue
escogido además como mejor jugador de la
copa américa y como el máximo goleador
e inicia la cuenta regresiva para la
final de la eurocopa 2020 entre
inglaterra e italia este domingo
24 equipos 11 ciudades 30 días y 50
partidos y todo se reduce al domingo
inglaterra se enfrenta a italia en la
final de la eurocopa 2020 bajo la
dirección de roberto mancini el equipo
italiano atraviesa un buen momento no ha
perdido en 33 partidos por detrás en el
mediocampo jorginho y marcó berti
dirigen sin esfuerzo el juego mientras
que las voces de la experiencia leonardo
bonucci giorgio chiellini forman una
muralla en la defensa la azurri le ha
ganado inglaterra cada vez que se han
enfrentado caras en un campeonato mayor
sin embargo no subestimarán a su rival
pensado si no pones todo tu corazón no
puedes ganar una final en wembley contra
inglaterra
tenemos que estar despreocupados y un
poco locos estos ingredientes son los
que nos han permitido llegar donde
estamos y son los que pueden ayudarnos a
ganar el campeonato ario aunque están
confiados muchos hinchas de italia dicen
que aceptarán cualquier resultado y que
el mejor equipo debe ganar si perdemos
nos quedamos en casa y comemos pasta si
ganamos salimos a celebrar hoy eso es
todo hay que tener esperanza de que
italia lo hará por nosotros
historia espera los tres leones en
wembley han pasado 55 años desde que la
reina isabel entregó la copa del mundo
al entonces capitán inglés bobby moore
ningún equipo inglés ha logrado llegar a
la final en un campeonato principal
hasta ahora pero con javi cane
encabezando la delantera y con jorge
mestre link disparando todos los balones
y con una rígida defensa liderada por
javi maguire y johnston los hinchas
creen que el destino podría estar
finalmente de su lado la mayoría de
fanáticos van a ser ingleses todos están
listos para ganar si hay un tiempo es
este habiendo eliminado a selecciones
como alemania y dinamarca en la recta
final el técnico gareth southgate dice
que están listos para un último empujón
y llevar la copa a casa bien faustino es
un juego brillante en el que participar
un juego brillante para prepararnos para
ello estamos en la final y estamos acá
para ganar
con todo en orden ambos equipos buscarán
escribir sus nombres en el folklore
futbolístico pero al final sólo un
equipo podrá coronarse campeón de europa
y la humanidad se prepara para
presenciar hoy un hito en el turismo
espacial virgin galactic del
multimillonario británico richard
branson enviará un avión
cohete de pasajeros a la frontera del
espacio en su primer vuelo de prueba con
tripulación desde el estado de nuevo
méxico lugar desde donde despegará el
vehículo se encuentra nuestro enviado
especial alto nivel si con los detalles
richard branson hará historia al
convertirse en el primer multimillonario
en viajar al espacio a bordo de una
aeronave que él mismo ha financiado a
través de su compañía virgin galactic
con esta hazaña el británico se situará
a la cabeza de la carrera por los viajes
turísticos a la estratosfera algo que
también están siguiendo muy de cerca el
lo más que el fundador de tesla y jeff
bezos de amazon de hecho este último
había anunciado que viajaría al espacio
el próximo 20 de julio pero aunque
branson ha dicho que esto no es una
carrera por llegar el primero lo cierto
es que su compañía movió fichas
rápidamente para avanzar el viaje del
magnate y así convertirse en el primero
de ellos en realizar una experiencia de
este tipo la salida se ha [__] un
poco pero se espera que en unas dos
horas y media el pie sea ese y unite y
despegue desde el aeropuerto espacial
space port en la ciudad de truth or
consequences aquí en nuevo méxico unas
instalaciones de última generación
situadas en medio del desierto que
también fueron financiadas por el
magnate en por el magnate del reino
unido branson ha admitido que siempre ha
soñado con ir al espacio y fue por eso
que en 2004 hace 17 años fundó virgin
galactic
ha dicho que este sueño se va a hacer
realidad está previsto que la
experiencia dura aproximadamente unos 90
minutos en el espacio donde esté
triplicar a la velocidad del sonido a
unos tres mil setecientos kilómetros por
hora y a una altura de 80 kilómetros no
lo hará solo también le acompañan tres
de sus compañeros de trabajo en virgin
galactic y que en los últimos meses han
estado trabajando en este proyecto que
de alguna manera abre las puertas al
turismo espacial un negocio que el
propio branson quiere impulsar a partir
del próximo año tiene un costo de 250
mil dólares y según la compañía unas
distintas personas ya están en la lista
de espera para formar parte de este
viaje hasta aquí este informativo
quédense con nosotros
[Música]